okay if she needs three meals and two
snacks per day but half of her food ends
up on her face does that mean I need to
do twice as many airplanes how does your
face get even cuter with food all over
it okay don't panic
last bite our appointment is in 20
minutes it takes 10 minutes to get there
and 2 minutes to grab stuff if I'm quick
five minutes to put her in the car seat
that's 17 minutes which leaves us three
minutes - uh-oh dirty diapers this I
guess we're going to be a little late
Wow are we really bringing all of this
going to see grandma and grandpa for two
days so we need at least three changes
per day by the time I decide cuz she
won't even fit into any of these is it
dorky if we match but it's so cute when
we match today should be pretty chill we
have play time a couple of naps lunch
storytime snacks dinner bath okay that's
actually a lot but at least I know she's
getting the nutrition she needs I wish
she could stay this little forever but I
love watching her grow I guess every
spoonful counts for both of us
Oh